um what was the hardest part about that
about doing that part about being being
in the uh many uh saints of new york i
think it was letting go it was like just
keep going down this avenue just keep
going like this is what you rehearse
this with your practice this is what you
prepared so trust it you've done this
process and so many other projects why
don't you just continue down it
it's challenging do you watch yourself
yeah oh does a a carpenter look at a
table after he built it yeah but there's
some some actors who don't like to watch
i think that's weird man it i think it's
weird too and i think it's i
think every actor says no i don't watch
myself they watch themselves
guaranteed yeah of course they do
because again you can't see what you're
doing you can't learn or you can't grow
unless they really don't and you're like
that's why they do the same thing over
and over again yeah yeah you have to you
have to be
invested in yourself not in like a
selfish way but like this is your the in
the acting career like we are the
product that's what sucks like you are
the product so you have to constantly
mold it and shape it and work on it and
right which is exhausting i the problem
i had actually one of my biggest
failures was um connecting my self-worth
to my career and i hate that feeling
explain that
explain that um your self-worth to your
career like are you are you worthy yeah
are you good enough to be this part to
be a successful actor to be someone that
people want to hire no you i you know
this this game is a uh
it's a game of knows how many notes have
you gotten and a million it takes an
interest i'm waiting on a note today
today i hope it's uh it's it's at least
maybe trying to sell a show i pitched
and wrote and i thought it was wonderful
and i felt like that you know the
president was in the meeting and he felt
i felt like he loved it but like you
know i'm so used to rejection now that
it's just like
how am i gonna prepare and usually i'm
like okay let's go to the next one let's
go the next one but sometimes you go
this
this is it me or no well maybe but no
it's like this is too good what's the
problem yeah what is this sometimes it
probably sometimes has nothing to do
with actually the project that's what's
crazy and that's what i'm saying like
talk like disassociate yourself from
the the product like the the career how
do you do that i have no clue man you're
still you're still wondering about that
you still have self-doubt you still like
you have questions
you do of course
again but all you can do is let it go
you say that so freely like i just let
it go do you really just let it go no
there's nights i've stayed up there's
weeks i've gone through this i haven't
i've been self-sabotaging myself over
and over again but like
yeah
but what what value does that actually
bring to my life what's nothing brings
nothing
yeah so it's just kind of constantly
going back it's a practice you know it's
not something like you'll uh run lines
and you're nervous and you're like want
to be great you get on there and you
know the first take's not great you're
like in your head a little bit you know
you have to and sometimes you say to
yourself
everybody here
because at the end of the day when this
say they say cut
i'm on screen yeah so what do i give a
about anybody just have and those
are the days where i was the best or i
just said this is for me i'm
full of confidence and it wasn't all the
time
yeah but when i felt that i go why can't
you feel like that all the time and what
is it about that why can't we just once
we it's almost like my mind is like
you're great so the next time you should
be great yeah why don't you why do you
feel like right now why don't you
feel confident so i wanted to rephrase
what you kind of said you said
everyone here i think that that everyone
here is actually yourself and you go
myself myself myself
that's not everyone has nothing to do
with anyone else it's actually the fight
you're having in your your own head yes